oh my goodness
welcome back it's time for drew's news
and joining me
at the desk is the other p in my news
pod
ross matthew hi everybody hi yes yes
thank you so much
i'm wearing an ascot and gloves because
omg drew
i can't believe we're going to meet
these people i am uh
tripping right now
we are so obsessed with this show i
can't even tell you we've been talking
about it a lot
as basically i feel like every person on
the globe has been
and we have very special guests today
they're the stars of the steamy
new brilliant netflix hit bridgerton
the show that is revving everybody's
motors hello take a look
you appear displeased do i
we find ourselves seated beside each
other miss bridgeton
i'd like to think you're happy about
that perhaps your grace
it would be better if you refrain from
thinking about me at all
ross and i were like we can't believe
we're about to meet them like right now
you guys it's like about to happen right
now
reggae jean-page and phoebe denver the
stars of brisbane
[Applause]
and look you guys nice guys my goodness
we are
dorking out just a little bit it is so
nice to meet you
yes you guys look amazing oh
yeah i know thank you i would have
dressed up for the occasion if i knew
i'm so sorry i feel like i've let the
side down you look just fine
yeah you're perfect and we're just doing
a little ode
to your show um you brought
so much to your characters we were all
in love at first sight
i mean that's what you want isn't it
that means so much coming from you
i mean we really are starstruck right
now i how did you guys
prepare for the role i heard there was
like etiquette lessons by the way can
you teach us something about etiquette
yeah because we could use a tip i mean
we it was a long process we had six
weeks i mean me and regular were both
living in l.a at the time so we both
sort of touched down
in london together to start this crazy
journey
and it was like our schedule was like
horse riding and
etiquette lessons and dance rehearsals
and
i mean it was it was kind of crazy i
think um we're all ready to
to get on the marriage mart now i feel
very fully prepared
we're incredibly well drilled in this
stuff and you guys are doing great by
the way the language of the fans going
on there and
the koi little ascot and the gloves like
i'm taking notes this is great well we
really legitimately talked about what we
wanted to wear because we are
fully obsessed and you said you took
etiquette lessons is there anything that
we're doing improperly other than
everything yeah other than you know
everything
um nothing at all no
no no no you guys are flawless you
couldn't possibly do anything wrong we
wouldn't dream of
saying so if you did i've been waiting
my whole life to hear you say that thank
you so much
um you guys uh yeah i said the first
like five episodes were very sweet
watching your dynamics right and then
episode five okay
a lot goes on with you two
i'm curious i'm talking about like love
scenes and whatnot i'm curious
uh when you knew the world was gonna
watch it were you nervous at all
about like your family saying that
because they're kind of intense
i mean my family pretty well drilled at
this point we've got a family whatsapp
group it's got like the little red
flashing light emojis particularly
around
episode five that's the one occasional
peach emoji
uh but also the brits are very well
drilled for this in general i have a
cousin who
missed those messages who made a bunch
of tactical cups of tea she told me you
know you just kind of you just leave the
room and put the kettle on
for no particular reason you're not
disturbed you just need to make a very
long cup of tea right now
um but the problem with this show is
that she came back and she was like and
you guys were still
going how many cups of tea do i need to
make
i heard you watched it with your
grandparents yes
i did but only because and i find it
really hard to watch myself but i
i had to if they were going to watch it
so i had to stand there with the remote
ready at any given point to fast forward
and
for them not to see any of the bits i
didn't want them to see
it's very responsive so we were good we
got through it and
yeah i've had cg 13 for my parents for
my grandparents sorry
i would love to see that version i'd be
interested
um i i've had the i'm not sure i want to
see that in fast forward
i think that might be a whole new show
like cue the william tell over at your
speaking of
incredible health by the way
totally um speaking of orchestral
majesty uh the vitamin string quartet
who are the composers of the show i was
lucky enough to work with them they were
the composers on the one film i've been
lucky enough to direct
called whip it and uh it was about a
decade ago and i've been such big fans
of theirs my jaw almost fell
on the floor they made such an impact in
your show
they have underscored everything that
makes this show the emotional behemoth
that it is
yeah i think they do half the chemistry
work for us to be honest
i think it's absolutely pretty much all
of them yeah and they mix in like modern
day hits but in a classical style it's
very
very cool i think thank you i know it's
amazing that's something that we talked
about a lot in rehearsal as well that
the
emotional core of these characters and
the show is modern it is 21st century
like
the way people love or the way people
want to find their sense of identity in
a society that restricts them in various
ways that's
universal that's not something that's
removed from us in the 19th century
and so we rehearse to modern music to
try and find that energy to make sure
that it hits an
audience in a very raw and emotional way
that isn't
kind of removed from themselves in any
way and i think it was super clever how
they then kept that energy
whilst just transporting it into a
regency flavor and that way you get
that bit of fantasy that bit of
something exotic and different but also
something that you recognize
in your own heart in yourself and that's
i think what the
love story is doing all over to be
honest i think that was a real we also
never knew
what they were going to do with the
music because we rehearsed everything to
modern music but there was always a
conversation about
were they going to use modern were they
going to go with you know classical
so to have that mix i mean i remember
watching it for the first time and
hearing thank you next ariana grande and
be like
oh my gosh it's that moment as an
audience you really connect with it
because you know it
so it's yeah it's fun i love reading the
production designer stayed up all night
with the obsession of what was the
perfect shade of blue for the parlor
room and the bridgerton family house and
it's such a gorgeous set i'm glad
that it meant so much to him because it
affects you watching it
oh absolutely and the care that they put
into all of this
is immense i think we don't get to talk
about that enough because a production
like this like you'll have
phoebe and i turn up on the show but
we're talking hundreds and hundreds of
people who put their hearts and souls
into each stroke of paint in the
bridgeton room
every choice of the shade of blue like
you said every choice of stitching
i think at one point someone told me
that we had a crew larger than star wars
so like we're not
messing around with this it's a lot of
people's hard work
um and i'm incredibly kind of gratified
to see that paying off and reaching so
many people as a result
yeah and it all works it all comes
together the show is just so
great and i still cannot believe i'm
talking to you i know
i know right how is it like for you on
the other side of it because we're all
watching it
and you know really just enamored and
excited and
wrapped up in the two of you uh your
chemistry your dynamic the choices
that you made um conscious or not
is what everybody's responding to what
do you guys have to say in response to
everybody's
response to this i mean it's been
wild i think we were really excited
about the fans of the books being able
to see the show and that that's
who i was thinking about the whole time
like oh gosh we have a real brazilian
fan base that love the books and the
fact that it's spoken to
such a wider audience and you know we've
brought so many people into this
you know exciting world it's crazy but
just to know that it's given
people joy in this you know really weird
time is
lovely and it we're so pleased
for that i talked quite a lot with uh
betsy via one of our producers about
this about how
one of the differences between this and
other period pieces is that period
pieces can tend to have this kind of
puritan energy
um and bridgeton is just unashamed of
its own joy
it's unashamed of its own indulgences
which don't necessarily
uh act as any kind of hindrance it just
isn't ashamed of letting us be happy of
letting us
enjoy these moments of socializing in
closeness and overblown romance that
we're all
missing right now because we're all
isolated from each other and so a show
that allows us to get close to each
other
not just physically but emotionally in
ways that normally we
are in some way mildly ashamed of
releasing that corset if you will um i
think has been something relatively
uh powerful in this moment in time i
i fully agree yeah
well i we think the world of you
yeah this this went really well for me
did you guys have fun i feel good
we had the best time right because we
don't understand what an honor this is
on this side of the camera thank you so
much for having us it's
a genuine pleasure and seeing you guys
like dress up for us and everything this
is insane
literally we were like doing lamaze in
the commercial break just trying to like
prepare ourselves
to say hi to you so thank you so much
for just making such a beautiful show
that is so modern that feels so
now even though it's based so long ago
and for um
really turning our engines back on if
you know what i mean it's true i got
back on a dating app after uh during
bridger10 i was like i'm not
dead i'm not dead yeah yes true
i didn't know that that was the most
that we were going to turn on but
for me that was a big step um but
i i i think you know uh colin firth said
something i believe it was to rooney
mara at the oscars he says now that you
have come into the world
we cannot imagine it without you that's
how i feel about you guys
oh wow that's amazing that means a lot
wow and those kinds of words thanks so
much this is the truth and i'm sure
everybody is dying to speak to you so
please thank you
and know how grateful we are for your
time here at this show
the feeling's very mutual it really is
thanks guys reggae and phoebe i'd go
binge bridgerton if you haven't already
robin's on her second round
and uh you certainly won't regret it
it'll wake you up
you